boop
one decision
five million dollars a year i lost as a
result of this
i want to tell you about one of the
scariest decisions i've ever made my
entire life which was when i had my gyms
i
was selling a boot camp at the time this
is before i knew a lot about pricing and
i was charging 99 a month
and i uh got really fed up at one point
and i was like i don't think i'm helping
people i want to have semi-private
because this is where people are really
going to transform their bodies and i
want to sell with conviction right so
just keynote sidenote pro tip life hack
if you can sell something that you truly
believe in you'll make a lot more money
and so i had gotten to the point where i
didn't really believe in boot camp
as a vehicle for for personal
transformation in terms of body wise and
so i was so convicted about our summer
private program because clients were
getting way better results there that i
wanted to switch all my clients over
that now i couldn't do that at 99 a
month and so i sent a mass letter out to
my customers that said we were going to
go from 99 a month
to 299 per month so i was going to
triple my prices
add more value but i was going to triple
my prices all right and at the end of
this video i'll tell you what happened
when i sent that email out now what i
want to do is tell you a secondary story
of a similar situation that happened
later on in my business career all right
and it was we were we were selling our
uh program at 42 000 per year all right
um at the time
and that was being billed at 800 bucks a
week roughly all right
and i uh wanted to decrease our churn
and so i've been i was trying to figure
out a way to decrease our turn so we
could extend you know increase our
lifetime value per customer
and i kept you know all my my team and
all that stuff they're like we have to
lower our price we have to lower our
price and i hate i hate lowering prices
i don't like lowering prices it just
generally doesn't mean you make more
money after a long time i said you know
what fine we're going to add more
and we're going to go to 600 per week
all right that's what we're gonna do all
right which if you're doing the math
it's like 31k that's what i decided to
do let me tell you what happened in each
of these scenarios as soon as i made
this change right here all right so what
i did was i did this big announcement i
said we're going to roll out this new
additional services program and i did
this huge presentation in this huge
pitch i stacked it and stacked it and
stacked it and i was like and you're
going to get all this stuff
and you're all going to get a discount
and that's what i said and everyone was
like yay i actually did have one person
complain to me um they said why are you
doing this now you should have been
discounting us before which just goes to
show you that no one will ever be happy
with what you're doing i was literally
saying that they can pay less and i got
somebody upset with me and so anyways i
decreased the price and so this is what
ended up happening
my churn remained completely unchanged
and i lost
five million dollars
per year
in profit boop
one decision
five million dollars a year i lost as a
result of this and so i can tell you
firsthand most times when you lower your
prices you make a lot less money and so
what happened to me is that my overhead
stayed the same it actually went up a
little bit so i added about 100k a month
in in overhead to my business so that i
could add for this this new service all
right and then i decreased my price by
25
so imagine cutting top line by 25 which
is literally what i did
and by making this little beautiful
combination so i increased my cost by 1
million dollars and i decreased my my
top line by 400 000
per month
at the time for that business it sucked
because here's the beautiful thing i
thought hey if i decrease this price if
i can cut our churn by half right which
is what i thought i was going to be able
to do if i could cut my churn in half
let's say from 10 to 5 i would still 2x
ltv so i'd rather decrease by 25 percent
but then 2xl tv i'll take that trade
every time right
aha
but that's not what happened
turns stayed the same
and i just lost 25 of top line which if
we were running a 50 margin business
right i just lost half my profit which
we weren't we were actually running a 70
margin business at the time right and so
i actually cut my income by a third
which sucked for that business it was
not fun i highly recommend not doing it
and so that was the first thing that
happened so let me tell you the story
that i started with this puppy all right
where i had
my clients and i told them all hey this
is what we're gonna do i'm gonna give
you two weeks for free so i did have to
front this labor two weeks free of this
new service it's much better
you're gonna get way more personalized
attention you're gonna be lifting
weights you're gonna learn form all this
type of stuff
and i said after those two weeks
you're gonna automatically all be
enrolled at 299 per month
let me know if this is going to
materially affect your life and you
won't be able to buy groceries as a
result of this decision so here's what
happened one third
of my customers left they said alex you
suck i can't believe you're raising
prices on us
blah blah blah two-thirds of them stayed
at
three times the price what happened
i 2xed the revenue of my business
and
i serviced
only
two-thirds of my customers which means
my cost of fulfillment went down and my
revenue went up
excellent combination
and so by doing that one thing i was
able to more than
2x the profit of my business and so i
tell both of these cautionary tales as i
was petrified to make both of these
decisions
one of them dramatically increased the
profit of my business the other one
dramatically decreased the profit of my
business
in most cases
providing more value and charging a
higher price in order to provide the
higher value will make you more money
because you will service fewer people at
higher prices the reverse of trying to
service more people at lower prices by
also providing more things
most times will make you less money
especially in a service-based business
and so i tell this cautionary tale
because it makes me sick to think about
it but hopefully
it uh it makes you sick to think about
it and if you're contemplating what
should i do with my prices because i
would like to increase my ltv the ltv
can be increased in six ways all right
number one you increase your price
number two you decrease your costs and
then number three four
five six
are
resales get people to buy more times
upsells
get them to buy more of the stuff
they're currently buying
cross sells
get them to buy different things down
sells
get people who are not going to buy to
buy something all right so this is
you're buying burgers once a week now i
want you to buy burgers twice a week
this is you go from a small burger to a
big burger this is would you like fries
with your burger
this is would you like a junior burger
instead of your current burger so that
you buy more or buy something instead of
buying nothing so these are the six ways
that you increase
ltv you'll notice
what i was trying to do was get more
people to do this
and i cut this
and i lost and so i tell this story to
hopefully get more people to not make
the terrible mistake that i did and i
have learned that painstakingly and most
times i would say 99 times out of 100
when you lower the price
you make less money
sometimes you make more but the vast
majority of time you make less so and
i'll tell you one final thing to
illustrate this concept that i think
everyone should understand so let's say
you've got a 100 thing here
and let's say your profit is 40 bucks
if you decrease your price to 80 bucks
right on this product you would have to
sell two times as many people at this
lower price because you have half the
profit
right
say this is cost most times if you make
this kind of change you're not going to
two extra sales
but you will
make half the money so make sure that
when you're making these changes and
here's the flip side if you were to take
this and go to 150
right now you're making
let's say we're now making ninety
dollars so we more than 2x our profit
you probably won't sell half as many
customers
you might just sell three quarters as
many customers
and make two times the money
which means more than what you're making
now
small tweaks big changes lots of impact
think through these decisions my name is
alex mozy own acquisition.com we have a
portfolio company of 85 million dollars
in revenue yearly and i have absolutely
nothing to sell you my goal is that for
everybody in this channel there's a lot
of people who are broken i don't want
you to be one of them if you enjoyed
this you found value in this in your own
business hit the subscribe button so we
can give you more vids like this and if
you did not i love you either way
keeping awesome and i'll catch you guys
next vid bye